transition into that because i i want to
i want to go into that which is
you know uh most most the average person
is like oh my god i don't want a nuclear
war what if there's a nuclear war what
happens how bad is it how you know ugly
is it going to get if there's somebody
does something like that like truman did
back in the days when we responded back
to pearl harbor all this other stuff
okay fine for you what concerns you more
nuclear war cyber warfare biochemical
warfare or a super emp type of attack
that you know i i read this somewhere
that says experts say our power grid can
be destroyed and when that happens
seven or ninety percent of u.s
population will die within the first
year
which of those four concerns you the
most
well i i put
super emp and cyber together uh you know
my in my book blackout warfare i
described this revolutionary new way of
warfare that is in military doctrines
of russia china north korea and iran
and they are prepared to execute this
where
the focus of the attack is
national electric grids okay because we
are an electronic civilization uh and uh
and uh everything all of our
life-sustaining critical infrastructures
communications transportation even food
and water
uh depend upon electricity
and uh the military the ability to
project power to operate your military
forces and command and control all
depends upon electricity
uh so the theory of this uh you know is
uh is that if you can take out the
electric grids with emp attacks and
cyber warfare and special forces
sabotage small numbers of guys going in
and shooting up transformers and stuff
uh you know
cause a nationwide blackout and that
will bring
the other side to its knees and you'll
basically win a war and
very quickly potentially at the speed of
light you know because of the way emp
and cyber work and not and because it's
uh uh
even a new what so-called nuclear emp
attack is not
a hiroshima or a nagasaki type use of an
atomic bomb uh it's not considered
nuclear war in russian or chinese north
korean doctrines considered part of
cyber warfare electronic warfare and
rightly so because of the way the
physics work you know you detonate a
weapon
at a very high altitude 300 400
kilometers it's so high that if you were
standing on the ground directly beneath
the explosion you wouldn't even hear it
i mean it's 300 400 kilometers over your
head going off in the vacuum of space
there wouldn't even be a noise all right
the the blast wouldn't reach you that
there'd be no thermal or radioactive
effects that would reach you the only
thing that would come down would be the
electromagnetic pulse which is harmless
to people it passes harmlessly through
your body like a radio wave but it will
destroy electronics cars won't work you
won't have any water because it required
the electric grid would collapse and
requires millions and volts to get water
food would start spoiling you know
there's only enough food to feed people
at three days in local grocery stores
and in the whole of the united states we
only have enough food to supply people
for 30 days 330 million people for 30
days at normal consumption rates and it
would begin to a spoil immediately and
it couldn't be transported to market
because the interstate highways would be
jammed transportation systems wouldn't
work
in effect
it's a way of subtracting from modern
electronic civilization
you know the technologies that make life
possible today and uh
a president faced with that you know
wouldn't be able to operate his forces
you might not even be
able to retaliate with a super emp
weapon because it would fry the
electronics and command and control
systems and the missiles and the bombers
and
faced with
do i go and fight a losing war in
ukraine or do i mobilize what is left of
the defense department to try to restore
the electric grid to save millions of
american lives before people start
starving to death and society collapses
obviously that ladder choice and that's
part of their calculation and we're even
closer to that i'm most concerned about
that scenario because before russia goes
nuclear in terms of the classical
nuclear war where they would blow up
icbms in their silos or or
or attack bomber bases with nuclear
weapons or or even do tactical nuclear
strikes in ukraine you know uh you know
i think it's more likely that they would
use
what i call a blackout war you know
because this is
it it would kill very few people
initially it's a it's a it's what's
called gray zone aggression you know uh
it it it's a non-traditional way of
warfare that we really have no way of
responding to and it could be
very quick and very decisive uh and to
solve the problem without having to go
to a large-scale nuclear exchange
so i think
you know we're even closer to that than
we are to a nuclear war and i think it
very likely that they would exercise
that option before they went uh before
they went nuclear so if you like this
clip and you want to watch another one
click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]